all right I am here to tell you about
the reliable maintenance of machine
learning models my name is Julia syi and
I work at pit on open source tooling for
um for mlops TAS things like versioning
deploying and monitoring your model and
I work on the V framework which is for R
and python a ways to approach these
kinds of tasks since this
talk is about maintenance we're
definitely kind of at the end we're
really talking about you've already
deployed a model there um what do you do
at that point but before we really get
started I think there's something you
should know about me um I love finishing
projects I love checking things off
checklist I love I'm I I am very
motivated like if a project is kind of
almost done like to really do whatever
it takes like get that over the end I
love shipping stuff um like this just
kind of how I'm wired up and this of
course plays out in my work life but it
also plays out in my non-w work my real
life and just as an example um I if I'm
coming home from a trip and I arrive at
my house with my suitcase I unpack that
basically right away like certainly
before I go to bed that night probably
within that hour of getting home
honestly it is sometimes the first thing
that I do when I get home cuz otherwise
that suitcase is just sitting there need
to be dealt with it's hanging over my
head I I can't relax until that suitcase
is unpacked because I know I need to
take care of
it I'm sad to tell you that M
maintaining machine learning models is
nothing like the process of unpacking a
suitcase it's not it doesn't have like a
beginning and an end and instead the
work the job of maintaining machine
learning models is like the process of
doing
laundry we we do laundry all the time
we're never done doing laundry you can
catch up with laundry on one day but
guess what there's going to be more
laundry to do the next day and
maintaining machine learning models is
like this and that it is this
NeverEnding process that that um has to
be done U forever much like we have to
decide um when is it appropriate to
start a new load of laundry we have to
decide when how in what
circumstances um are we going to re
train a model now it's true that all
software products have to be maintained
I don't think I at least I have never
been able to write a piece of software
that does not require some kind of
Maintenance but machine learning models
are unique in that they have both
software characteristics or properties
and also statistical characteristics or
properties so let's think about
something that does not have any
statistical properties it's just
software it's just code like an example
of this would be air fairly
straightforward shiny app um unlike that
something that's only software when it
comes to a model you could entirely
retrain the model with new data and just
totally change its um uh it statistical
properties and you can not change at
software properties at all so we have
different kind like when machine
learning models are complex products and
that they have they are both software
products and statistical products when
whether we're talking about the software
or the statistical properties what we're
really talking about is performance and
one of the just most basic prerequisites
for model maintenance is monitoring that
performance so when we monitor when we
measure model performance this lets us
say my model is performing well but it
turns out if you hear someone say that
or you're having a conversation about
that people can mean different things
when they say this so this person what
she means is when she says this is my
model returns predictions quickly
it doesn't use too much memory or
processing power and it doesn't have
outages these are statements about the
model's software characteristics and the
kind of things you want to measure the
metrics the way you would measure this
kind of performance is with um metrics
like latency or
uptime another person when they say my
model is performing well they may mean
something different so this person when
she is saying this she means that the
model returns predictions that are close
to the True Values for whatever it is
that we're trying to um predict here so
I am I consider myself by by um
profession largely a data practitioner
and I bet in this audience that is true
of most of you as well and as data
practitioners we are we focus on the
monitoring this kind of statistical
performance I'm not saying you never
have to learn about or work on the
software characteristics of your models
you almost certainly will but we are
unique ly responsible for these
statistical characteristics of our
machine learning models cuz if we don't
do it nobody will there's no one else
who cares about this and will make sure
that this is in good shape and it's
important to think about that because um
oops I didn't pop it up these kind of
metrics here so it's important to think
about that because failures in
statistical performance kind of has this
very unique tendency towards silence
let's say your model has a problem with
latency it's returning predictions
slowly something is happening typically
that will be noticed typically that that
some that will cause a problem in your
system such that you know you can then
go in and change it what if your model
is has great latency it's returning
predictions really fast but actually the
predictions are
nonsense it is very possible for you not
to know unless you are actively looking
for that so statistical performance
performance it is easier to have
problems that you don't know about
there's some vocabulary around these
kind of problems you may have turn this
heard this term model drift I love this
term it's very evocative to me model is
drifting off away from where I need it
to be so that's a generic or general
term um and there are also more specific
terms we're going to talk about two the
first one is data drift and the second
one is concept drift so let's say that I
run a laundry Sur service in um my city
and I'm going to build a model to
predict whether someone's going to be my
customer I use inputs features
predictors to the model maybe I use
things like how many loads of laundry a
household needs to do a month maybe
income maybe whether someone lives in a
house or an apartment I use these inputs
to um to train a model and get a
predicted probability that someone will
be my um my customer data drift is about
shift drift change
in those inputs and it compare when I
use the model compared to when I
developed the model so how do you
measure this how do you know you have it
using tools you are probably very
familiar with things like summarization
visualization let's let's look at a like
a per possible example let's say on the
x- axis here is the number of loads of
laundry that a um household needs to do
every month so I'm you I built my model
I'm using it in my business I'm going
along and I'm I'm going to keep track of
the distribution that I see as I'm using
it to know if I have experiencing model
drift I need to compare it to what I had
when I trained the model so if it looks
like this I might think I'm a okay I
don't those like look like they're drawn
from the same distribution I'm okay I'm
talking about comparing this visually
but you can also use any of the
statistical tests that are appropriate
to the kind of data you have to do this
kind of measurement if by contrast I see
something like this then I know
something has changed the distribution
of this thing I'm using as a feature has
changed if it's important in the model
if it changes that means the outputs
from my model will change as well I'm
going to get a different distribution of
predictions than I would have thought so
data drift to understand if you have
data drift you need to monitor your
inputs concept drift is about the
relationship between the input and the
output and concept drift means that is
changing over time so let's say in the
city where I have my laundry um service
a bunch of new apartments are being
built and all the new apartments have
laundry units inside of the apartments
if house versus apartment is a feature
that I use in my model the fact that the
apartments the nature of them is
changing means I will have concept drift
the relationship between this feature
and my output is changing over time so
with Concept drift it's not enough only
to monitor your inputs but we also need
to monitor your outputs this is a place
that vver comes in because we're now
talking about specific machine learning
statistical kind of performance and
either in r or python we have functions
that say you have some laundry service
monitoring data you can use the
functions to compute the metrics
measuring the statistical performance of
your model at some given time
aggregation with the metrics that are
important to you in your in your um in
your laundry service business that
you're that you're clearly running so V
also has functions to help you get
started with these kind of basic plots
and because what you get everything you
have access to is code you can extend
these you can add on to these here now
one thing that it's important to know as
we start talking about model monitoring
is that the fact that you put a model
into a
system actually can cause those things
we were just talking about data drift
and or concept drift we talk about this
um we call this feedback loops so what
What's Happening Here is the user if a
user takes some action as a result of a
prediction um or if you have users like
correcting predictions um or some
systems produce kind of feedback
automatically to be a little more
concrete about this let's walk through a
couple of examples many of us I expect
are customers of a streaming service
like like Netflix or Hulu so in those
apps you will see recommend Ed pieces of
content those are that's driven by
Machine learning models and if you click
if you choose one of those um one of
those recommendations that's a signal to
the system that that prediction was good
that data is collected and then used to
in uh improve the model this is an
example of a good feedback loop sorry to
report um that not all feedback loops
are good there's a really interesting
case study from stripe where they had a
data set of credit card transactions and
they trained a model to predict which
ones were
fraudulent um they they then took that
model which looked great and they put
they put it into their system in a way
such that they blocked the credit card
transactions they actually never became
credit card transactions some of you may
be seeing where this is going so they
you know over there you were using the
model A as happens with models in
production it gradually started doing a
little bit worse when they went to try
to retrain their model they did not have
they had not captured information to be
able to treat them like credit card
transactions anymore so they actually
could not retrain their model so they
had to go back do new data engineering
so that they captured information in a
different way and put these data sets
together to be able to retrain their
model this is an example of a feedback
loop that's bad for a um like a single
company but we actually have evidence of
feedback loops that can be bad for us as
a society as a whole if you take data
from say arrest and try to train a model
to predict say what areas of a town or
city are going to have more crime in
them and then take some intervention
based on that prediction you can end up
with a feedback loop depending on the
the nature of the inter intervention
that makes th certain areas actually
worse off you can make certain
neighborhoods have worse experience than
if you didn't use a model at all okay
okay so I've got one more kind of piece
of like one more kind of topic that I
want to talk about as I'm coming here to
the end of my talk and that is about
talking about the stages of model
monitoring maturity so the first stage
is just that you do it at all and
honestly it's a huge step it's a huge
step but often we start out doing things
manually so picture yourself you are um
uh you deployed a model last week and
then a product manager sends you a slack
message and and she says um how is that
model doing you run a query you make a
plot you do a statistical test and then
you share that in slack with the product
manager so that is like a first step of
model monitoring maturity the next step
is to make that reproducible so you take
that code that you wrote you arrange it
in a script you check it into Version
Control and then next week when a
different person asks you the same
question you can give them a
reproducible answer the next stage of
model monitoring maturity is to move to
autom ated model monitoring so here you
take that code that you checked into
Version Control you rearrange it so it
is a um um it is a report or it is a
dashboard and you you publish it
somewhere so that it automates it
updates automatically May some example
you can use a Cron job for this you know
posit connect of course has like
features for doing this kind of like
automated updating so now anytime anyone
wants to know how is the model doing you
have one place to look that is automated
on the appropriate schedule for your
particular use case v again here comes
in with tooling wherever you are on in
these stages to help you move to the
next stage as one example the r package
has in it a um a flex dashboard template
for getting started with model
monitoring to make a nice dashboard for
you to be able to share with your
co-workers it has code that allows you
to see okay here's how I would make a
plot measuring statistical performance
here is how it would make a plot
monitoring inputs here is how my model
works here I can share this visual
documentation so people can understand
what the inputs and outputs for my model
are okay so what we've talked about is
understanding what performance means
when it comes to models and how we are
it's important to understand both the
software and the statistical
characteristics of a model we've talked
about measuring both inputs and outputs
to really get a handle on these
different kinds of drift and this is um
I want to say like this is the knowledge
to have and also this is what we need
tools really nice tools to be able to
work on in order to have a model that's
easier to maintain a model that's
resilient and a model that is successful
not just at the moment when we deploy it
but a model that is successful in the
long term um you may have noticed
there's a URL at the bottom of these
slides and um these slides are posted
there you can go and visit all the links
that I included and I especially invite
you if you're interested in getting
started um with model monitoring or even
some of those earlier stages like
deploying your model to check out V see
if it's a good fit for you whether you
work in r or in Python and with that I
will say thank you so much and see if
there's any time for
[Applause]
questions we do indeed have a few
minutes for questions so so um if you
haven't already loaded up uh the slide
up page for this uh room please do do so
and submit any questions you have um I
do have one on the screen um so the
question is does model mod does model
monitoring tie in with model fairness oh
that's a great question so much like
during model development when you're
making a model you might want to measure
model fairness for say different
versions of a model or you might want to
even tune a model with its hyperprint so
it has the fairness characteristics that
you have in the same way you can use
fairness metrics when you're monitoring
so over time you can you can measure and
keep a track on how these kinds of
fairness can work so when people say
fairness they're usually talking about
metrics so picture these as um picture
these as uh things you measure about a
model usually disaggregated by some
protected characteristics and the other
sort of related thing is um would be
explainability so sometimes people say
fairness and are a little vague but
fairness metrics absolutely fits
perfectly in this explainability um you
would you would probably not monitor
explainability over time but rather make
sure you can return explainability with
any given
prediction thank you one more question
one more yeah just enough time uh is
there a way to put confidence intervals
on the monitoring metrics ah yes so
depending on the aggregation the time
aggreg
that you use for um model monitoring you
have a certain number of observations in
then and then you can use the the um
when you have that sort of feedback loop
where you have the real answer of
whatever the prediction should be you
depending let's say in a in a week you
get you have a thousand examples you can
use those thousand examples to estimate
a exactly a confidence interval on what
the um uh or an interval on the um on
the uh
metric that you're measuring thank you
let's thank Julia again thank
[Applause]
you